So I want us to run through the forms of aberr, this to have that we use to go into the past.
We said that we can remember them by looking at the two vowel sounds that we have inside the word aber.
So give me I have and we have.
Eh and emos.
Good.
And give me the rest of the versions.
A, as, an.
Good.
We said that nouns ending A are feminine nouns.
So for example, the house, la casa.
So words ending A are feminine, but
Words ending MA are masculine.
There's a small group of words that end MA which are masculine words.
For example, the problem in Spanish is el problema.
El problema.
Good.
How would you say?
Have you understood the problem?
What was to understand?
Comprender.
Good.
We can use Comprender.
Or we can use Entender.
But Comprehender is perfect here as well.
Have you understood the problem?
And let's talk
Fumily to usted.
A intendido el problema.
Good.
A entendido el problema.
So a very common error for people learning Spanish is to say la problema.
Now if we look at why these words ending M-A
are actually masculine is going to help us internalize it.
So these words the M the M A actually come from Greek.
Problema in Greek is provlima.
System in Greek is SISTA.
In Spanish it's Systema.
So how would you say the system?
El sistema.
So it's L.
Now in Greek these words are neuter words.
In Greek you have masculine, feminine, and neuter.
And neutral words in Greek look like masculine words.
They have a similar word for the.
They look kind of like masculine words.
So when they went in
to Spanish or into Latin, they could mistaken as masculine words.
So if we can identify them, there's a key group of words we can avoid committing this error with.
If it ends M A
It's probably from Greek and probably masculine.
So how would you say the system again?
El sistema.
How would you say have you understood the system?
Talking informally.
Have you understood the system?
Good.
Has entendido el sistema?
Sentir in Spanish.
Sentir is to feel.
Related to sensation, so sentir to feel.
And you can also use it like to perceive in the sense of smell.
So if you wanted to ask for example, have you felt the aroma?
It would be a way of asking, have you smelt the aroma?
Have you felt it?
So how would you say that?
Have you felt the aroma?
Has sentido el aroma.
Good.
So el again.
So we have el problema, el sistema, el programa, el aroma, el panorama, el clima, which is a little bit different in English, which means climate, el clima, and some others.
Have you understood the program?
Good.
Again, how was to lose perishable?
Perdir close perder perder good so how would you say I have lost?
Good now what if you wanted to emphasize I have lost
Yo he perdido.
Good.
Now if you want to say I have got lost, I've got lost
You can just say I've lost myself.
We said I get ready is I prepare myself.
Me preparo.
We don't use this in Spanish, I get ready.
You say I ready myself
Me preparo.
So you don't say I get lost or I have got lost.
You say I have lost myself.
So how would you say that?
Me perdido.
Again.
Me he perdido.
Yes, when you say it fluently, it doesn't actually sound any different, which is why I asked for again to make sure that you were putting it.
Because the air
of me and the air of e.
We'll blend together.
Me perdido.
So that means I have lost myself or I've got lost.
Now what if you wanted to be emphatic as well and say I have lost myself?
Yo me he perdido.
Good.
How is you have lost?
Speaking informally.
Good.
Has perdido.
We said that the word for you in the sense of you lose, you see, not I see you, but you see.
is tu for informal you.
Tu.
So how would you say you have lost being emphatic?
Tu has perdido.
There's a bit of a contradiction there.
Good.
Tu has perdido.
So just as me can mean me or myself, te can mean you or yourself.
So how would you say you have got lost?
You have lost yourself.
Te has perdido.
Good.
And what if you wanted to be emphatic as well?
Tute has perdido.
Good.
Tute as perdido.
Very good.
What was we have from Aber?
Emos.
Good.
How would you say we have lost it?
We have lost it
Lo hemos perdido.
Now, how would you say we have lost ourselves or we've got lost?
And what if you wanted to say we have got lost?
We have lost ourselves
Nosotros nos hemos perdido.
Good.